landon what's shaking bro
not much man what's going on good you
gotta
you got one of those deep voices like a
radio voice yeah i've been told that
like pretty much my whole life
yeah good with shaking yeah well um you
know well first off you're talking about
those dogs
like yeah girls with pets you gotta
experience to share i do um so my last
girlfriend she had
two dogs i had my own dog um and we
moved in together
basically off of a one night stand
what are you guys like a lesbian couple
you move in right away dude whatever man
no it was it was more like uh
so we met on new year's banged it out
had crazy wild sex
slapping each other around just [ __ ]
really good stuff
yeah and uh turned into
because i was i was i'm a musician well
i kind of was until coveted hit
but i was working on a cruise type of
ship a riverboat
and so i'd be gone for like a month and
a half two months
come on back we'd hang out for a couple
weeks
i would go back on the boat you know and
then it turned into like
i'm feeling sad and lonely and
you know what interesting i'm actually
kind of thinking because
a big reason i ended up stopping doing
that was because
uh because of kind of what i was wanting
to ask about which was
dealing with loneliness
as a single guy me being a lone wolf
kind of
type um i don't necessarily like that
about myself
hold on um i'm 36 okay
i'm 36 i am more introverted or more
extroverted
i'm a little bit of both um but i can i
can be comfortable on either side
for the most part but i i guess i would
um
lean towards introverted um
but uh so you know the loneliness really
sinks in
um and and the idea of wanting to be
with somebody and there's this hopeless
romantic [ __ ] stupid idea in my head
that i've always hated
yeah you know um it's so frustrating um
i actually started watching your videos
after me and her broke up
how long ago was that um we broke up
uh let's see it was
october okay okay so i mean you've seen
a few of them now right so
what's the ask here like how do you get
over the loneliness
well um just kind of like i don't know
um
yeah i guess so because it's like you
know part of me is taking that pill and
i'm at this point now where i'm like you
know i don't
i don't really want to i don't know if i
want a relationship i see all these
miserable married people i see
you know and i can just i can the thing
about
dating now is like you can just pretty
much use tinder
to your way you know to an extent um i
know that's kind of awful but i mean you
can get laid that way
well i think that you know like as a guy
with with where you're at i mean you
should be coming up on your smv
peak you know which is usually mid to
late 30s
i mean it can push into the early 40s as
well too
um but um what do you do for a living
right now like you're working you said
you were
you were you're a musician working on
riverboats yeah i was
um uh i was basically a musician like a
touring musician for like 10 or 12 years
um and i'm not a front man i'm just a
side man i'm a bass player
okay um that's my main gig um
uh but now i'm working on cars
okay no it's like what you gonna do um
you know i'll say this like when it
comes to
camaraderie and loneliness
you should never rely on a woman to like
fill that for you
i think that that's a bad place to start
because um
anytime something can be taken away from
you it can become a vice it can be
something that can hurt you
you know even right um you know
everything you should in my view anyway
you should look at
every relationship and as difficult as
this might be to
understand it here and some people are
going to mad i can't believe he's going
to say this now
but everybody's disposable everybody's
replaceable
in fact even if you're in a good
long-term relationship
even if you're in a marriage if you're
in a dating type of scenario with a
chick for a while
she should know without you explicitly
saying you are replaceable but she
should know that she can be replaced
right she should know that she that that
she can't possibly ever
only ever be your only source of sexual
intimacy
ever for the rest of your life she has
to know that you have choices
whether or not you choose to exercise
them right now it doesn't matter but she
has to understand
that that you have options so
whenever you get like really uh
like meat hooked on to like one of these
girls like ah you know
she's she she's my one you know she's my
true one you know
we're soul mates sort of thing okay
well she's gone now right and you right
and you're left with your bass guitar
and your dog
and you know your job working your cards
like well what do i do now to fill that
fill that void the the camaraderie
like that like that friendship part i
think should come from men
right when i want to hang out with um
guys that shoot guns i got my boys that
do that
when i want to hang out with guys that
drive supercars fast and cause trouble
and we're on our radios and the cars
you know as we're driving and we you
know like do all that fun [ __ ] that
we're doing when we sit down and eat and
drink afterwards and all that stuff
i do that with my boys i mean sometimes
you know the girl will come along with
you for the ride from time to time
but it's primarily me and my boys sort
of thing those should be the
that that should be in my view the prime
source of camaraderie so that you're not
lonely right right now a woman
if she shows up and you know she's a
compliment to your life she's not the
focus
can be like you know the cherry on the
top of the cake it can be like the
whipped cream on the top of the cake
you've already got the cake all you're
doing is you're throwing something
pretty on top of it
right and if you can look at it that way
like i already have the cake i don't
care if the cherries on it or not
you're happy with the cake you know you
throw
a cherry on it you know your night can
be a little bit better right
you see it doesn't matter either way
it's still it doesn't matter either way
because you've still got the cake right
right
right that's the point that you have to
get to when it you know when it comes to
women i think that you have to be
comfortable by yourself
i mean right i realized i'm comfortable
by myself
sorry i i'm comfortable by myself i
but i'll tell you man i have so many
flaky friends
too you know what i mean are they
married yes dude they're married
that's why i'm in that age now it's like
they're all [ __ ] married they're all
uh
find some friends that aren't flaky and
married
because they're always going to have
boundaries because most guys go into
like beta bucks zone you know they go
through beta tization through a thousand
concessions in a marriage so they start
yes honey yes okay fine i'm not gonna
hang out with landon anymore yes i know
i can't play in the band whatever the
[ __ ] the reason is but they're always
gonna
you know create these boundaries so find
friends that that don't have that
problem
either they're single or they're in a
marriage where they're the head of the
household
and what they say goes and and you're
not going to run into flaking issues
right so that's the other part of it too
is you have to be fastidious about
who you're going to allow in your inner
circle you know you're going to draw a
perimeter
around yourself and the five people that
you want to spend the most time with
maybe it's five dudes maybe it's four
dudes and
one chick maybe it's one dude and four
chicks you know
you decide what it is that you want to
do but you only let people in on the
inner circle
to spend time with you if you know they
complement your life if they're not
flakes you know if they add value and
you know you can add some value to their
life as well
you just have to get you know a buddy of
mine once
once said if you're the smartest guy in
the room you're in the wrong room so if
you find yourself in a position where
you're dealing with flakes and losers
and people that
you know don't respect your time put
yourself in a better room so that you
expose yourself to better people
yeah i think i'm finding that i'm
finding that but i i realize
they've been friends for a long time who
cares doesn't matter yeah
i know just having to kick them to the
curb they're just well you don't have to
kick them to the curb man you just
don't you just don't acknowledge them
and you don't respond to them like if
they flaked on you two or three times in
a row
right okay the next time they're like
hey let's get together and you know the
guy's probably gonna flake you just
don't respond to him you go and make
plans with somebody else
right that's like i i [ __ ] hate that
excuse whenever something like well you
know i've known him since high school
right i used to date this channel
circle of friends okay for like 20 25
years like well i've known them since
high school they're losers
okay you know for these reasons like
legitimate
reasons right well since i don't give a
[ __ ]
we're going to do this and they're not
coming or they're not invited
right right you like you like you've got
to be fastidious with your time
if she wants to spend or if she wants to
spend time with people that are flakes
that are dumb that are dumb people in
the room
then hey don't be surprised if you don't
get great results out of life right
exactly that's constantly that's what
i'm vibing
yeah totally and that's want where you
bro man the cold hard truth that's all i
deliver if you want
you guys want rainbows and butterflies
talk to your mommy
all right man get some kleenex thank you
rich appreciate peace
you